[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paradies herzlich willkommen an
diesem freitagabend den sport hat
norbert lehmann für sie
in den nächsten 20 minuten schauen wir
unter anderem auf diese themen
92.000 infektionen an einem tag so viel
corona war noch nie jetzt kommt es
darauf an dass die zahlen nicht so
rasant steigen sagt der
gesundheitsminister
neue erkenntnisse zu einer unheilbaren
krankheit möglicherweise besteht ein
zusammenhang zwischen multipler sklerose
und einem weit verbreiteten herpesvirus
und neue runde im hickhack um djokovic
die behörden haben ihm sein visum für
australien entzogen trotzdem darf er
erst mal bleiben
sie sind seit beginn der pandemie drei
der prominentesten stimmen
gesundheitsminister lauterbach der
virologe drosten und ex-chef villa heute
äußerten sie sich gemeinsam zur krone
lage denn die zahlen gehen weiter klar
nach oben einen neuen höchstwert gibt es
bei der incident sie liegt aktuell bei 4
170,6 außerdem wurden so viele
neuinfektionen gemeldet wie noch nie
innerhalb eines tages mehr als
92.000 fälle das führt dazu dass in
deutschland jetzt gerade mehr als
800.000 menschen an kubik 19 erkrankt
sind also fast ein prozent der
bevölkerung und das sind nur die
entdeckten fälle karl hinterleitner
berichtet
die impfkampagne geht voran die zahl
derer die sich die schützende spritze
geben lassen steigt aber besonders für
die gefährdeten gruppen gilt es reicht
noch nicht wir haben diese im pflücke in
deutschland das sind 3 millionen über
60-jährige die gar nicht geimpft sind
und wahrscheinlich auch noch keine
infektion hatten und man könnte diese
zahl erhöhen denn man weiß inzwischen
man braucht für dieses omikron virus
wirklich auch die dritte impfung um
richtig geschützt zu sein und das sind
dann fast neun millionen in dieser
altersgruppe omikron ist in ganz
deutschland auf dem vormarsch nach der
die variante noch vor einer woche
lediglich 44 3 prozent aller infektionen
aus sind es jetzt schon 73 3 tendenz
steigend hier geld ist gegenzuhalten
meint der bundesgesundheitsminister
wir wollen aus steilen wand der
infektionszahlen wenn möglich einen
hügel machen oder wenn sich das nicht
vermeiden ist dass es an der wand ist
dass sie waren nicht so hoch ist das ist
das strategische ziel der
bundesregierung was dahinter steht es
wenn uns das gelänge hätten wir weniger
sterbefälle zu beklagen am morgen ändern
sich die quarantäne regel infizierte
müssen sieben tage in isolierung
kontaktpersonen in quarantäne aus der
sie sich mit pizza oder schnelltest
befreien können ohne test sind es zehn
tage für gemusterte kontaktpersonen
entfällt die quarantäne bei den pcr
tests gilt medizinisches personal hat
vorrang denn die kapazitäten kommen
durch omikron an ihre grenzen nikon hat
die lage verändert und kugelt 19 breitet
sich so stark in deutschland aus wie nie
wir haben die werkzeuge und wir können
infektionen vermeiden wenn auch nicht
jede infektion aber jede infektion die
wir verhindern trägt zur bewältigung der
welle 1 bei und auch dazu das
gesundheitssystem zu entlasten zur
entwarnung gebe es keinen grund eine
verschärfung der korona maßnahmen aber
sagt zurzeit nicht nötig
dass es bei einer kuh wie 19 erkrankung
um leben und tod gehen kann zeigt ein
blick auf die intensivstationen die
meisten der patientinnen und patienten
dort sind ungeimpft viele müssen
künstlich beatmet werden was das
bedeutet berichtet nicola albrecht aus
dem herzzentrum in cottbus
wie lang sie jetzt bei uns sind dann
ziemlich lange zeit nur 29 tagen schon
mal gehabt der stanz immer weg und haben
es geschafft matthias pohl ist einfach
nur glücklich dass er lebt signalisiert
er uns dennoch muss er beatmet werden
der mitte 40 jährige war nicht geimpft
mit einem so schweren verlauf hat er
nicht gerechnet es ist die sogenannte
eco die ihm vermutlich das leben
gerettet hat ein komplexes verfahren
dass das blut des patienten außerhalb
des körpers mit sauerstoff anreichern
und so die lunge entlastet
es dient letztendlich nur dazu
sich zeit zu nehmen damit die lunge
heilen kann dr bertram huber leitet die
intensivstation im herzzentrum in
cottbus und ist spezialist für die ecke
seitdem bekannt ist dass sie auch bei
cupid die letzte rettung sein kann
werden patienten mit schweren verläufen
hierher verlegt
dann wenn man dazu gezwungen wird dann
wenn die patienten wurden der
sauerstoffversorgung so schlecht sind
dass sie die nächsten paar stunden
überleben gehörten der technische und
personelle aufwand um die patienten
angemessen zu versorgen ist enorm vor
allem wenn sie noch hoch infektiös sind
wie diese patienten sie ist mitte
dreißig und seit mehr als einem monat an
der eco die prognose noch ungewiss und
auch nur durchhaltevermögen das ist
einfach sicher ist dann können sie sich
erholen aber es gibt natürlich auch
patienten die wir uns an welchen
verstören laut einer aktuellen studie
über leben in deutschland weniger als
die hälfte der kurve patienten die an
der ecke hängen in cottbus sind es
bisher drei viertel und matthias pohl
ist einer von ihnen rund ein jahr wird
er nun aller voraussicht nach brauchen
um wieder voll im leben zu stehen
wer zurzeit an restaurants oder kneipen
vorbeigeht sieht oft aushänge personal
gesucht wie kaum eine andere branche
wurde die gastronomie von corona
getroffen aktuelle zahlen zeigen heute
fast jeder vierte job ist weggefallen
beschäftigte haben sich andere arbeiten
gesucht auszubildende fehlen isabel de
la vega hat sich das genauer angeschaut
sandro auerbach ist personalchef eines
wiesbadener gastro betriebs wegen krone
hat das lumen nur noch an zwei tagen in
der woche auf zweig plus zeigt jetzt
zusätzlich seine wirkung dass die
reservierung stärke zurück geht ja und
dass wir überlegen müssen ob das sich
überhaupt rentiert an den wochenenden
überhaupt zu öffnen neben fehlenden
gästen ist das personal ein problem 30
bis 40 prozent des gesamten personals
steht uns die spiele zur verfügung
abgewandert in anderen branchen die
krisensicher sind ein großteil meiner
meinung meiner küche habe ich gehört
sind sitzen beim rewe oder beim netto in
der kasse die zahl der beschäftigten in
der gastronomie ist zwischen januar und
oktober 20 21 im vergleich zu 2009 10 um
23 prozent zurückgegangen bei den
kneipen und bars sind es sogar 45
prozent der fachkräftemangel ist
dramatisch wir haben de facto keinen
nachwuchs niemand der die berufe
erlernen will und das wird denke ich
schon zu einer noch stärkeren
verknappung der engpässe führen als das
in anderen branchen der fall ist eine
verlängerung staatlicher hilfen fordern
die gastwirte nun vor allem damit nicht
noch mehr mitarbeiter gehen das gilt
insbesondere für die erstattung der
sozialversicherungsbeiträge beim
kurzarbeitergeld dass das zu 100 prozent
weiter erstattet wird dass das
fortgeführt wird weil viele unternehmen
müssen auch jetzt das kurzarbeitergeld
aufstocken um einfach den die
mitarbeiter zu halten
auerbach weiß wenn corona abklingt folgt
die nächste mindestens ebenso große
herausforderung neues personal zu finden
und zur überwindung der pandemie wird ja
aufs impfung gesetzt das mainzer
unternehmen bei ihren tag ist dabei
durch die entwicklung seines impfstoffes
so erfolgreich dass es im vergangenen
jahr allein zu etwa 0,5 prozent zum
bruttoinlandsprodukt beigetragen hat
ziemlich außergewöhnlich
nichtsdestotrotz hat deutschland in
corona zeigt eine riesige schulden
angehäuft wie er diese begrenzen will
dazu heute im bundestag finanzminister
lindner ein bericht von markus wolsiffer
raus aus dem krisenmodus rein in den
gestaltungs modus das ist die botschaft
die finanzminister lindner heute im
bundestag vermitteln wollte zum beleg
hat der zahlen mitgebracht demnach habe
der bund im vergangenen jahr 24 8
milliarden euro weniger schulden
aufgenommen als geplant damit wird die
nettokreditaufnahme
reduziert wir tun also das was nötig ist
aber es wird nicht ausgereizt was
möglich wäre
dennoch hat der bund rekordschulden von
über 215 milliarden euro aufgenommen
weitere ungenutzte kredite in höhe von
60 milliarden will die ampel in einen
klimaforum wandeln die schuldenbremse
soll ab 20 23 wieder gelten damit
verbinden wir investitionen in die
mit der disziplin bei konsumausgaben in
der gegenwart dem geburten des
bundesverfassungsgerichts nach
generationengerechtigkeit werden wir so
gerecht und zwar gar in doppelter weise
die opposition kritisiert die
umschichtung als verfassungswidrig weil
die kredite für die pandemie gedacht
waren indes hat sich die deutsche
wirtschaft leicht erholt nach dem
einbruch 2020 ist das
bruttoinlandsprodukt zuletzt um 2,7
prozent gestiegen regierung und ökonomen
hatten mit mehr gerechnet doch es gibt
weiterhin probleme etwa lieferengpässe
halbleiter die nicht kommen das bremst
natürlich die produktion insbesondere
bei den automobilherstellern bei
maschinenbau es wird also noch dauern
bis sich die wirtschaft gänzlich von
corona schock erholt hat sie geht mit
immerhin etwas rückenwind ins dritte
jahr der pandemie
nachdem im bundestag diese woche also
die neuen minister und ministerinnen der
ampel koalition ihre pläne vorgestellt
haben wollen wir jetzt mal schauen wie
die neue regierung in der bevölkerung
ankommt dazu ist matthias fornoff mit
dem aktuellen zdf-politbarometer bei uns
im studio diego nahm matthias hallo hier
ist die neue bundesregierung bekommt ja
viel zustimmung der bevölkerung ja und
die befragten finden auch dass olaf
scholz gut im amt angekommen ist er
macht seine sache als kanzler er gut das
sagen 65 prozent und sogar die anhänger
der oppositionsparteien cdu csu und
linke stimmen dem mehrheitlich zu neuer
chef der cdu soll friedrich merz werden
kann er die partei erfolgreich in die
zukunft führen
40 prozent der deutschen trauen ihm das
zu 48 prozent nicht mehr optimismus bei
den anhängern der union
da glauben 68 prozent märz wird die cdu
erfolgreich führen und die blicken die
befragten auf die pandemie über die
aktuelle situation in der korona krise
die belastet mich stark sagt eine
mehrheit von 53 prozent im september war
die stimmung gelassener nur 39 prozent
fühlten sich da stark belastet bei der
viel diskutierten allgemeinen
impfpflicht sehen wir nach wie vor ein
klares bild im politbarometer
62 prozent sind für die impfpflicht 36
prozent dagegen etwa drei viertel der
anhänger von spd union und grünen sind
dafür mit großer mehrheit lehnen dagegen
die afg anhänger eine pflicht zum impfen
ab vielen dank für die zahl mit
glasfaser
und das gesamte politbarometer können
sie heute abend im heute journal sehen
und schon jetzt jederzeit online im
internet und in der zdf- heute- app zb
die beliebtheitswerte vieler
spitzenpolitikerinnen und -politiker
darunter die prominentesten vertreter
der neuen ampel koalition nach
london wegen diverser feste während der
lok downside ist der britische
premierminister johnson in bedrängnis
nun hat sich seine regierung bei der
queen persönlich entschuldigt für zwei
weitere partys am vorabend der
beisetzung von prinz philip an diesem
tag der nationalen trauer hatten nach
einem medienbericht etwa 30
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in
johnsons amtssitz downing street number
ten getrunken und getanzt
heute vor sechs monaten brach die
verheerende flutkatastrophe über das
aatal herein 134 menschen starben ein
untersuchungsausschuss mainzer landtag
soll nun eine entscheidende frage klären
wäre es möglich gewesen die menschen im
katastrophengebiet früher zu warnen die
klare aussage des sachverständigen heute
ja die warn und datenlage sei eindeutig
gewesen anna da
heftige regenfälle kleine flüsse werden
zu reißenden strömen allein hier in sind
sich stern zwölf personen in einer
einrichtung für menschen mit geistiger
behinderung sie werden nicht rechtzeitig
evakuiert hätte das verhindert werden
können darum geht es heute im
untersuchungsausschuss anhand der
wetterprognosen für den 14 juli
das ereignis kam nicht überraschend die
vorhersage war vorhanden dass ein
starkes regen ereignis stattfinden wird
mit grossen niederschlagsmengen die von
der menge her ausreichend einer
überflutung auszulösen und so gab es
eine ansage für diese katastrophe damit
sei klar die behörden hätten handeln
müssen anhand der niederschlags
vorhersage und der daten zur
bodenfeuchte gab es tage vor der
katastrophe auch projektionen zu
sturzfluten das europäische flut one
system efas gab vier tage im vorfeld der
katastrophe erste hinweise auf ein
mögliches hochwasser am 13 17 dann
morgens gab es für das aatal die höchste
warnstufe violett eine extreme sturzflut
wurde erwartet jetzt stellen sich
natürlich daraus hinkünftig die fragen
gab es brüche in den in den in den
warnungen in den meldungen nach
abgegeben worden sind erst am 14 07 hat
sich abgezeichnet dass im aartal in dem
engen tal etwas passiert und da hätte
die kreisverwaltung eben früher
reagieren müssen nicht erst um 23 9 wer
trägt die verantwortung diese frage ist
nicht nur für die menschen im aartal von
großem interesse
und jetzt zu einer vielleicht
bahnbrechenden forschung
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
haben möglicherweise einen
entscheidenden faktor für die entstehung
der nervenkrankheit multiple sklerose
entdeckt eine studie der universität
harvard liegt nahe dass sie die
spätfolge einer virusinfektion ist
auslöser könnte ein weit verbreiteter
herberger sein das epstein-barr-virus
schätzungen zufolge haben allein in
deutschland etwa 240.000 menschen
multiple sklerose weltweit 2,8 millionen
könnte eine impfung künftige weitere
fälle eindämmen alexandra vacano
ms genannt die krankheit der 1000
gesichter kann mit taubheitsgefühlen
losgehen sie oder
gleichgewichtsstörungen
bei ms attackieren die eigenen
abwehrzellen die zellen des zentralen
nervensystems zerstören ihre
isolationsschicht folge nervenimpulse
können nicht mehr richtig weitergeleitet
werden eine studie kommt der ursache
wohl einen schritt näher forschende
haben blutproben von 10 millionen
angestellten der us army ausgewertet
raus kam fast 95 prozent der männer und
frauen hatten eine infektion mit dem
epstein-barr-virus durchgemacht von den
armee angestellten erkrankten 800 und 1
an multipler sklerose
eine infektion mit dem
epstein-barr-virus erhöht die
wahrscheinlichkeit um das 32 fache an ms
zu erkranken laut studie ist dieses
virus also die hauptursache für diese
herpes virus infektion scheint ein
trigger zu sein und damit eine übel
zufällig häufige
konstellation die man so interpretieren
und das ist vielleicht der einzige
träger ist dazu so weit würde ich
allerdings nicht gehen denn mit dem
herpes virus infizieren sich mehr als 90
prozent aller menschen aber nur wenige
erkranken an ms eine zusätzliche rolle
spielen genetische wie auch
umweltfaktoren wie ein niedriger
vitamin-d-spiegel rauchen übergewicht
und schichtarbeit könnte eine impfung ms
verhindern dass eine impfung kerwel die
einer epstein barr virus infektionen
dauerhaft verhindern könnte diese
impfung auch dazu führen sollte dass die
personen keiner multiple sklerose
gekommen das bedeutet ms die krankheit
der 1000 gesichter würde dadurch nicht
heilbar aber verhinderbar
und nun zum fall novak djokovic norbert
dem droht er jetzt doch die abschiebung
australier und das ganz kurz vor beginn
der australian open am montag die
regierung hat heute das wiese und des
serbischen tennis stars anna
entschuldigung annulliert die anwälte
von djokovic haben widerspruch eingelegt
am sonntag soll ein bundesgericht eine
entscheidung treffen
novak djokovic polarisiert menschen und
medien ob als breaking news in
australien oder in den zeitungen in
serbien
der weltbeste tennisspieler neunmalige
rekord-sieger der australian open ist
nur noch gast auf zeit ihm droht die
unfreiwillige ausreise der
einwanderungsminister alex hock entzog
das visum nach langer hinhaltetaktik die
öffentliche meinung in belgrad man sei
über die australische regierung
enttäuscht
er ist dann sport sparen hatte corona
krone oder geben zu sein das ist doch
das gleiche
die widersprüche im fall von novak
djokovic zeitliche unstimmigkeiten bei
einem positiven kroner test keine
quarantäne eingehalten regelwidrige
reisen vor dem abflug nach australien
regeln sind regeln egal für wen ob es
für die nummer eins ist oder für eine
qualifikantin nach dem einspruch seiner
anwälte ist djokovic in dieser nacht
noch auf freiem fuß nach seiner anhörung
vor der einwanderungsbehörde am samstag
wieder ins gewahrsam genommen am sonntag
wird ein bundesgericht endgültig
entscheiden muss djokovic ausreisen oder
darf er spielen
bayern-verteidiger alfonso davis fällt
weiter für unbestimmte zeit aus nach der
korona infektion letzte woche haben die
ärzte nun bei einer nachuntersuchung
eine herzmuskelentzündung festgestellt
zum wintersport bei der parade wm in die
lama hat anna-lena forster die erste
deutsche goldmedaille gewonnen die
26-jährige mono ski fahrerin
triumphierte in der abfahrt der
sitzenden klasse mit 1,45 sekunden
vorsprung vor der niederländerin barbara
van bergen und feierte nach silber 2009
10 ihren ersten wm erfolg in dieser
disziplin und beim snowboard weltcup auf
der simonhöhe in österreich hat stefan
baumeister seinen zweiten saisonsieg
erzielt im finale des
parallel-riesenslaloms bezwang er den
slowenen tim massad
starke aufholjagd der deutschen
biathletinnen heute beim weltcup in
ruhpolding vanessa hinz als zweite
staffel läuferin beim schießen mit einem
blackout und strafrunde deutschland dann
auf platz 15 danach machten franziska
hildebrand und denise herrmann elf
plätze gut und mit rang vier für ein
versöhnliches ergebnis
am morgen mittag die männer-staffel bei
uns zu sehen und überhaupt jeder menge
wintersport live im zdf schon ab 39 sehr
schön da genau hat als sie auf den
dänischen thron stieg kam die
gratulation noch von bundeskanzler willy
brandt heute feiert mal geräte die
zweite ihr 50 jähriges thronjubiläum
größere feierlichkeiten sind legen der
korona pandemie auf den spätsommer
vertagt am morgen besuchte mal geräte
das grab ihres vaters nach dessen tod am
14 januar 1972 übernahm sie als
oberhaupt das riesige dänische
königreich zudem nicht nur unser
nachbarland zählt sondern auch die
eisige weite grönlands
ein eher trübes wochenende erwartet uns
ob es dabei trocken bleibt das erfahren
sie gleich von katja horneffer um 22.45
können sie es heute journal sehen mit
christian sievers auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend heute zogen dichtere wolken
über norddeutschland und die brachten
auch ein bisschen nieselregen mit
programmgemäß lockerten die wolken hier
am nachmittag an den küsten von nord-
und ostsee auf sonst gab es entweder
neben oder strahlenden sonnenschein der
nebel hielt sich zb an der donau auch am
mittel- und am oberrhein und der nebel
bild sich gleich wieder neue jetzt in
der nacht in norddeutschland sind die
wolken nach wie vor dichter und in
sachsen kann es auch noch ein bisschen
nieselregen geben unter den dichteren
wolken bleibt die nacht vergleichsweise
mild mit 5 bis 2 grad sonst reicht es
aber bei 0 bis -7 grad wieder mal für
glätte auf straßen und gehwegen morgen
die höchsttemperaturen zwischen 1 und 7
grad und das wird ein sehr drüber
samstag vielleicht sehen sie die sonne
mal hier so an der ostseeküste ganz im
westen vor allen dingen aber wieder auf
den bergen süddeutschlands und dort
reicht es dann morgen vielleicht auch
schon wieder für acht sonnenstunden
sonst sind das meer so 0 bis 2
sonnenstunden und am sonntag wird es
eher noch trüber sein mal abgesehen vom
äußersten südwesten von nordwesten
kommen regen wolken heran und das bei
temperaturen von null bis acht grad
guten abend